there is something about ramona like she
kind of does that like remember in true
blood when like the vampire like looks
into your
glamouring clamoring sorry i can make
all this go away from
there you go i feel like ramona like
glamorous people
leah we gotta talk about the real
housewives of new york we have to get
into it
your first season is coming to an end
and i don't know if there has been a
first
season housewife who has been more
welcomed
by the bravo community than you have you
fully processed that
um no yeah of course like it's been so
nice and it's so
great because obviously like the show
airing and the pandemic happening at the
same time
i can't imagine if what if like i
everyone hated me and they were like
harassing me on social media i would not
be able to deal with that and the
pandemic at the same time right now
i just wouldn't be able to so god gives
you only what you can handle
and honestly i would not be able to
handle that um anyway it's
it's so nice it really it's nice to have
support you've been such a breath of
fresh air on the show and you've brought
us so many things we haven't seen before
including our first confessional in a
sweatshirt
which i know it's your brand so it's
like free advertising but
i was like this is a choice leah i know
i just was like you know what the
kardashians wear
sweatshirts and they're confessionals
why not try it out i mean i get it
they're the kardashians and like
i get it but still i mean why not it was
it was a pandemic but then i was like
all right since i did the sweatshirt
let me go overboard with my red and
yellow tie
i love the unitard thing yes you
you hit both ends of the spectrum there
fashion risks i can't i can't help it
then your the reunion fashions have been
revealed and you gave us a look that um
i'm sure ramona singer had some things
to say about
mona i mean look ramona said she liked
it but who knows i mean she
sang to my face she liked it we'll see i
mean i don't know if she was i think she
was telling the truth i'm not sure
well how did the first reunion go was it
everything you expected it to be nothing
like you expected it to be
first of all i need to say that the
amount of
work that i know went behind the scenes
to put that reunion on in person
was extraordinary and like unlike
anything
they've ever done before and i'm so
grateful for them that they did that
because the fans are gonna be so happy
we were so happy i was so happy because
i can't even imagine doing my first
reunion
over zoom i mean i had to do watch what
happens live over zoom i've had to do
every single press interview
everything has been over zoom you know
um
so the fact that we got to do this
reunion in person was just
it's awesome it was great to see the
women too i have to tell you it was good
yeah human interaction for the first
time in a while
exactly was it dramatic how would you
describe the day
oh my god first of all i don't think
one person didn't shed a tear
except andy i think he was crying but
everyone else definitely cried at one
point or another
everyone um great to see tinsley great
to have her
on and speak her truth get get some
things off her chest she had to get off
her chest
and uh the drama happened so
quickly like the fighting started
happening like
before i even like when it was just time
for us to talk about what we were
wearing it already started i'm like this
is crazy like is this supposed to be
going on right now i think they're all
like yes it is
so tinsley made it in person i was
wondering if she was going to be calling
in virtually or what but she's there on
the couch
okay um stairs not couch stairs oh
separate you had to be separated so
that'll be it's it's not quite the
reunion we know
right got it but it didn't feel like we
were far away we we were all six feet
apart
um but it felt like we were right next
to each other
you know maybe the six feet was probably
good
it was it made people sick like someone
got up to like hug and i was like no
no don't do that don't do that so that
part was like a little sad
actually but maybe it was better that no
one can get into each other's faces and
scream
uh will fans be happy to see the
resolution with tinsley
is there a resolution with tinsley and
kind of like the durand of it all
no comment i'm gonna take your laugh as
a no
[Laughter]
saying anything you gotta tune in you
gotta watch you know
there's a lot of resolution though that
does come
like i definitely left feeling like a
lot of things were resolved
some things weren't but a lot of things
were
what about you and ramona ramona is a
terrible person
and everybody knows this
she doesn't support women and she's
phony
and she singles me out and you're one of
her best friends and she treats you like
because that's a ramona you know what i
and i feel like i didn't even get to see
this at the reunion so i'm gonna say it
now
maybe i did i don't know but watching
in hindsight i'm like i actually let
ramona get away with so much
i mean albeit was my first season
i'm trying to navigate i'm trying to be
respectful i'm trying to also
be me um
so i feel like that's never gonna happen
again
so if you could go back and do it again
you would have called ramona on her
stuff more
no because i'm not gonna i'm not like i
can't go back and i can't change and i
was just being me
that was me but watching it i'm like wow
okay
now i feel a little bit different now
i'm a little more used to it i'm a
little confident
like i know all the women a lot better i
know ramona
a lot better i won't be holding back as
much let's put it that way so
in terms of the the you know conflict
with ramona i will say this
i'm a person that doesn't really hold
grudges
i believe in forgiveness i believe in
atonement i believe in
owning up to my own stuff and i'm all
about the resolution
so as the season has gone on it seems
like more and more
of the cast is kind of over ramona's
antics and then her behavior during the
pandemic has only added to that
feeling so so does that
all get addressed at the reunion okay
what do you make of ramona kind of using
the excuse that you two have a
mother-daughter relationship and that's
why she feels okay crossing boundaries
including talking about your mental
health
right i don't you know i
just don't believe that i think i was
dealing with issues with my mom
at the same time as dealing with issues
with ramona
i don't know i mean there is something
about ramona like she kind of does that
like remember in true blood when the the
clamoring is that what it's called when
like the vampire like looks into your
glamouring clamoring sorry
now you can pull his mind into yours
everything's gonna be okay there's
nothing of fear
i feel like ramona like glamorous people
like i feel like she says glamouring
like i'm not even kidding like
she just does so it was hard to stay mad
at her
i mean even in mexico as you saw
i was like all right let's just move on
like
i'm sorry i made you feel uncomfortable
i'm sorry i let my
feelings expectations affect everything
i just want to go forward with you okay
that's the best comparison she goes into
this head voice anytime she's like
changes her voice yeah when somebody
confronts her about her behavior she
gets into this head voice and she hugs
the person and then
she fake cries or actual cries to be
determined
only ramona knows only god knows um and
then they everything moves on so i was
like this is
a pattern oh i get it now i get it she's
one of a kind she's a special
special human what can i say i feel like
a lot of the fan conversation around the
season has been like maybe ramona's
time with the group has is over like
maybe
everyone is tired of her did does it
feel that way for you after the reunion
or there's still space for ramona
i don't think it feels that way i can't
really imagine it without her
you know you're not like just because
she's
not a good like all you know people are
saying she's not a good person or
whatever like that doesn't mean that
she's not
good for the show this is true there's i
think that's been an interesting
discussion even like in kind of the
social movement happening about
holding reality stars accountable where
it's like well a lot of reality stars
aren't really on tv
because they're moral compasses like
right the fact that they're not moral
compasses is why they're on tv
it's so true it's so true and also if
we're all
the same it will be boring you know
like of course you don't want to be you
know
also this is the other thing it's like
things that were acceptable 10 years ago
where people thought were funny or
whatever
is changed right you can expect someone
to just know that
without telling them first you know and
you can't expect someone to be able to
change
overnight or at all really so
it's complicated does ramona now know
the difference between all lives matter
and black lives matter
i think she does she said she does she
said she was uneducated i mean i don't
know if that's really an excuse because
she says she travels the world
she says she's like this and that and
worldly and cultured and
you know it's hard to know whether
someone because i i
do believe that some people say all
lives matter and they really think with
all the best intentions
they're saying something good right they
are they think they really are saying
something good because in essence of
course all lives do matter but the whole
point is like
black lives don't matter enough so you
can't say all lives matter
right yet you know right um but i don't
think a lot of people don't know that
they just yeah it's until black lives
are equal
we cannot say all that data exactly is
the cameo seen around the world
addressed at the reunion i have a friend
who wants to give you a little t on why
ramona can't meet a man
she during sex oh no no no no
it is briefly yeah i don't think it's
something she wanted to um
give too much air time too okay she
tweeted an apology to you about bringing
up your bipolar diagnosis
have you gotten an actual apology from
her an in-person apology
not exactly i got a an in-person apology
for going around the table and saying
everyone raised amazing daughters
but she didn't mention my name oh we're
the best daughters sonia's daughter
my daughter your daughter grands
daughter elisa's daughter
i don't know your daughter that's
disgusting there's definitely like i got
a few apologies at the reunion
i'll tell you i'll say that does have
the nickname
the apologizer so right exactly but she
also was like well i don't want to
keep apologizing well then don't say
black to me you know
i think something that became a little
apparent when tinsley left was there's
there's an age gap between you and the
other ladies
do you feel like as the show moves into
a new season and the cast is definitely
gonna there's gonna be new people like
there just has to be
do you think it needs to expand a little
younger maybe a little more diverse
yeah i mean i think diversity across the
board in terms of
age ethnicity um
thought you know i mean everything just
just diversity in general that's
interesting
would your sister ever come and be a
housewife
i don't know i don't know if she would
really want to do a full-time
apple holder thing you know i don't know
about that i don't know if she'd
be into that and then like i just can't
help but think about kim and kyle
and like the fights that they had and
like
did you hear what you just said kim oh
you out of your [ __ ]
mind you are so sick but i love her
so my sister's so freaking smart and so
funny and so entertaining
and young and hot and you know all that
so like she would also be so great
for it you know and people would enjoy
her so much so
that would really be up to her and bravo
okay we'll put it out there i
want to see it we've got only a handful
of episodes left before the reunion
what plays out before the end of the
season that the fans should get excited
about or scared for
i know right um i think the season
finale is
something something something special
it's i think unlike anything that
you've ever seen why i'm not saying why
i can't say why
this season a lot of the commentary this
season has been that so much has been
fueled by drinking
and alcohol um correct me if i'm wrong
but
you returned to a.a during the pandemic
i
returned to not drinking yes
how did why did you come to that
decision and that choice
so um i mean honestly
i really just can't deal with hangovers
i can't do it just cannot can't i live
almost a decade
of my young adult life or adult life i
guess whatever young adult
i'm still kind of young um not drinking
you know
i'm obsessed with being productive to a
fault sometimes and like it's very hard
for me to be productive when i'm
hungover i love getting drunk i can't
even lie
i love it it was fun doing it i'm glad
i'm happy that it's now
immortalized and on season 12 for all to
enjoy
but it's very hard for me to be
productive like when hungover
and like also like nothing bad happened
but i was like you know what something
bad's possibly gonna happen and like
the stakes are high it's not worth it
it's just not worth it and you know i
stopped and
i was like you know what i was like let
me try sobbing for a bit and see how i
like it i just
i did you know i'm just much more used
to living my life without alcohol in it
are you saying you're done uh with
drinking for good i would say i'm
pretty committed yeah you know i was
hadn't drank in so long and i was
testing things out it just so happened
that like
it was a few months before someone
reached out about doing this
and it that all gets addressed at the
reunion too
you know all right well you're
entertaining with or without without
alcohol
you bring it all
[Music]